Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain a surreal black comedy dystopian film
“The Lobster.” Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
In the near dystopian future, not being in a
relationship is considered a crime. To survive in
the world, one should always be with a romantic
partner. People must go everywhere with their
partners or else they are punishable by law.
The newly single people are brought to a hotel
that gives them a chance to find a romantic
partner in the course of forty-five days.
If they are unable to find one, they are turned
into an animal of their choice through a modern
technique. The opening scene of the movie shows
us a woman driving down a road until she reaches a
field with small donkeys. She gets out of her car
and shoots one of the donkeys until it is dead.
The protagonist of the movie is an architect
named David. His wife has recently left him
for another man, so he has been brought to the
hotel to find another partner. David is with
his dog, Bob who used to be his brother but was
transformed for having no romantic partner.
To check into the hotel, David signs a paper
and is interviewed by a hotel staff member.
According to the rules of dating, the couple
should have a common defining characteristic.
David’s defining characteristic is that he
is shortsighted, meaning, he should look for
a partner who is shortsighted as well. David also
reveals that he had been with his wife for eleven
years but she left him for another short-sighted
man. After that, he is taken to his room and
is briefed about the rules of the hotel by the
manager and her husband. When the manager asks
him what kind of animal he would be if he doesn’t
find a partner, David replies that he wants to be
a lobster because they live for over a hundred
years and are fertile throughout their life.
He also adds that he loves the sea and is quite
good at swimming. The manager praises his choice
of animal claiming that most choose to be dogs
which affects the ecosystem and animal food chain.
Before they leave, the hotel’s maid cuffs
one of David’s hands to keep him from
pleasuring himself against the hotel’s rules.
The following day at breakfast, he makes friends
with two men, one who speaks with a lisp, Robert,
and one who walks with a limp, John. They both
are searching for girls with the same attributes
as them. While skimming through the dining area,
they notice a woman whose nose always bleeds and a
woman who is heartless. But there is no one whose
attributes align with theirs. Later, during an
assembly, the singles are called up to speak and
talk about their unique qualities. John says that
he acquired his limp when he visited his mother
who had turned into a wolf. He is here because
his wife died some time ago. Similarly, the others
share their experiences. Throughout the day, the
signals are given opportunities to talk to their
potential partners. At a dance party, David
asks the nosebleed girl to dance with him but
realizes that they do not have a common attribute.
Following that, they are called to go to the woods
to hunt the Loners. Loners are the people who ran
away from the hotel because they didn’t want to
be turned into animals. Since the police in
the city would send them back to the hotel,
they form a colony and stay in the woods.
The singles are allowed to hunt them by shooting
them with tranquilizers. Then, the loners are
brought back to the hotel and turned into animals.
The number of Lonars the singles catch will be
added to the number of days they have left in
the hotel. On the first day, David catches none,
meaning that his days are going down rapidly.
The best hunter among the singles is
the heartless woman who kills about ten
in a single hunt. The hotel also has weird rules
that at night, the maid should arouse the men,
so they are interested in finding a partner
quicker. One day, Robert is found pleasuring
himself and as a punishment, his hand is
burnt in a toaster. In their next hunt,
David sits next to the woman whose characteristic
feature is that she likes butter biscuits.
She talks to David who shows no interest in her,
even when she offers sexual favors. While talking
she reveals that she plans to jump off the window
of her room if she doesn’t get a partner in time.
During a swimming season, John, the guy who
limps, hits his nose making it bleed. He then
approaches the nosebleed girl, lying that his nose
bleeds all the time, to match their attributes.
At the next evening party, John and the nosebleed
girl are pronounced a couple and are shifted to a
double room. A few days later, the butter biscuits
girl jumps off her window and commits suicide. The
ruthless girl watches her whimper in pain but
doesn’t get up to help her. David only has a
week left to find himself a girl, so he approaches
the heartless girl acting like he doesn’t care for
people’s lives either. The woman is looking for
someone who has no emotions, like her, so she is
attracted to David. They hang out and talk for a
while, throughout which, David keeps on the act.
One day, they are in a hot tub where the woman
fakes her death to see if David cares. However,
he stays in his seat and ignores her completely.
This makes the woman realize that he is actually
like her and she starts to date him. They are
even put together in a double room and allowed to
perform activities reserved for only couples, like
playing tennis and sitting at a table for two.
They stay as a couple for a few days but the
ruthless girl notices David showing emotions
when they get intimate. So, one morning, she
kicks his brother dog to death to test him.
David says that it is no problem at first but
then, the woman finds him crying in the bathroom.
She drags him through the hallways to take him
to the manager for lying but David knocks her out
with a tranquilizer gun before she can. The maid
watches him do so and promises to not tell anyone.
To take revenge for his brother, David thinks of
kicking her in the stomach again and again but
settles to another plan. He and the maid get her
to the transformation room and turn her into an
animal. Following that, David runs away from the
hotel once and for all. In the woods, he meets a
group of loners and their leader. One might think
he is finally with good people but the leader is
as ruthless as the hotel manager. She punishes
the loners for having a romantic or sexual
relationship with each other. They also inform
David that two people’s lips were cut off a few
days ago because they were flirting. After they
explain the rules, he is welcomed to the group.
One of the loner girls with black hair and
shortsightedness like David looks at him for
the first time and is instantly attracted to him.
But because of the Loner’s rule, she only talks to
him as a friend. In the evening, when the hotel
guests come for the hunt, Robert catches David.
David tries to save his life claiming that Robert
is his best friend but the guy is adamant about
catching him because he has only two days left.
The black-haired girl hits him from behind and
saves David’s life. At the same time, we see
the maid of the hotel meeting the leader Loner.
It turns out that the two meet every time she
comes hunting to inform the leader about what is
going on at the hotel. The maid is not happy with
her husband but doesn’t want to leave him because
she will end up in the hotel as a guest. So, she
and the leader are planning to attack the hotel
and take over it. Once every month, two people
from the loners pretend to be a couple and
go outside to the city to get food and other
supplies. This time, the leader and her partner
take the black-haired girl and David. In the mall,
a police officer sees David alone and questions
him about his partner demanding a marriage
certificate from him. But the dark-haired
girl saves him from the man. Some days later, the
loners finally get ready to attack the hotel.
That night, they sneak inside with the maid’s
help and hold the manager and her husband hostage.
They ask the husband to shoot his wife
dead if he wants to save his life.
The guy doesn’t care about his wife at all so
he shoots her without hesitating. But It turns
out that the gun was unloaded and the purpose
of the abduction was to show the couple they
do not care about each other and are in a hollow
relationship. At the same time, David visits John
and the nosebleed girl and reveals to her that he
is faking the nosebleed so they would be together.
The loners leave abruptly after proving their
point and return back to the woods. That night,
the maid joins the loner group. In the course
of the next few days, the black-haired girl and
David get closer and start liking each other. They
even plan to run away from the group so they could
be together. The girl writes all of this in her
journal. But before they can execute their plan,
the leader reads the journal and gets to know
about their affair. She is enraged by the betrayal
but doesn’t confront them. Instead, some days
later, she takes the dark-haired girl to the city
claiming that she will fix her shortsightedness,
but instead, makes her go blind.
After returning to the woods, the dark-haired girl
finds out what is going on and tries to kill the
leader. In the attempt, she kills the hotel’s
maid instead. The leader spares her and lets her
go to David. At first, she tries to hide the fact
that she has gone blind but then comes clean. She
is scared that he will leave her, now that they
do not have any matching attributes. David is
unsettled, but decides that he wants to stay with
her, and helps her out with her other senses of
touch and smell. For the next few days, they try
to find other attributes that they might have in
common but are unsuccessful. David doesn’t want to
let go of her so he suggests they kill the leader
and run away from the woods. They put their plan
into action at night. David abducts the leader
and throws her into an open grave. A while later,
some wild dogs approach her and start devouring
her body. Meanwhile, he and the dark-haired
girl dress up and run away from the woods.
Eventually, they stop at a diner in the city.
David has decided to blind himself so the two have
matching qualities. They talk for a while about
the decision and ask the waiter for a knife. David
gets up and goes to the bathroom to blind himself
but stops midway. The movie ends abruptly, without
showing if they ever lived a normal life.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out. Thanks for watching.